and for corbin he continues to have such
great success here in 2021 yeah no
kidding i mean uh four may starts he did
spend some time on the injured list a
313 era
0-2 lack of run support has been an
issue for him went right back to it that
is strike three called
run away
just did clip the edge
pretty close to the same spot maybe a
little bit up higher than the one before
but he did get his strikeout right on
the edge just like pitch number five
that was called a ball but that went up
a little bit more and gets the call
burns looking for a three-up and three
down inning there was only one thrown by
the brewers yesterday and it was in the
ninth
here's a swing in a minute corbin burns
hangs a zero on the bound for the
diamondbacks in this series finale the
lefty caleb smith getting another start
following his return to the rotation
last tuesday against the mets one he was
impressive two runs five innings he
looked good curious leading off
got it in there and got the call from
dan belino
let's start for caleb smith williams
swinging a miss chased a high heater
two up two down for smith smith who had
just two strikeouts in his last start
strikes out the first two batters in the
game
three hits couple of walks in the series
he's homered twice
he's on deck
fastball is drilled deep to right field
pavon smith is at the wall and he's got
it pavon smith
reels it in as yelts drives one deep to
right
[Applause]
one ball two strikes
the pitch
strike him out swinging
he is retired six in order has struck
out three niel garcia the right fielder
leads off the milwaukee second
rips it to left
david peralta trapped it did he get it
and as david all right remember he had a
very serious wrist injury several years
ago
on a very similar play
wound up needing surgery it's kind of
it's hard to read the ball off the bat
there because they're kind of in the
dark
behind home plate but that is kind of
regrouping the rule of the catch and
david fortunately appears to be okay
two outs
and caleb smith gets his third strikeout
six up six down for caleb
nick ahmed leading things off for the
diamondbacks in the third check swing
did he go he went strikeout number four
for corbin burns
there's that two seamer at 97 third
baseman today ill demarro vargas here's
the 2-2 pitch to vargas swinging a miss
breaking ball down and away and vargas
went after it
strikeout number five for corbin burns
there's two down here in the third as
the pitcher caleb smith is the batter oh
two pitch
called third strike corbin burns
with a cutter at 96 and he strikes out
the side here in the top of the third
justin hero leads off from milwaukee
here at daniel robertson and corbin
burns the hitters
called strike three strikes out looking
strikeout number four
one two
called strike three on the inside
quarter
slider in off the plate
dan bellino called it a strike two outs
that's now five strikeouts for caleb
smith and he faces the pitcher burns
here's the pitch
called strike three on the inside corner
only asked caleb smith to match corbin
burns he did he strikes out the side in
the third he has six strikeouts through
three
josh rojas took a call third strike on
that corner on the outside corner
unfair at that right there clutter up
and then change up down and away another
strikeout give him seven martay flied
out his first time
there's a ball on the ground and that's
a base hit the first for either side of
the ball game can tell martay a
one-ounce single in the fourth man
aboard 3-2 staying put
strike three called right at the knees
right at the knees down the middle of
the plate and kelly takes it smith the
great hitter
struck him
down
he's got nine strikeouts for four
innings back to the top of the order for
the crew urea sadamas and yelich
[Music]
there you go second time through the
batting order was pretty good for the
diamondbacks and good start for the
brewers second time through
bases are going to be loaded and tyron
taylor coming up
and caleb smith get out of this mess
yes
gotta get there first paving has got it
caleb smith leaves them loaded to combat
a strikeout victim his first time
nine strikeouts so far for corbin bird
there's another strikeout that's his
tenth
got ahmed for a second time that's why
that pitch count is so high right now
that one not even close to cutter way
off the outside corner and ahmed just
chases it eighth career 10 strikeout
game for burns
0-2 pitch
got him looking
11 strikeouts for corbin burns through
five innings here's daniel robertson
after casting hero strikes out
robertson to deep left
this one's got a shot peralta
daniel robertson puts the brewers on the
board
he's hit some big homers i mean his two
homers have been really important for
this team
and the timing is everything for the
home run robertson gets the brewers on
the board
a big fly way back second deck in left
[Music]
right over the middle of the plate ahmed
cleans it up in front of rojas and caleb
smith gets away
corbin burns out there again for the
sixth he has struck out 11 batters in
this game along just two singles rojas
struck out twice swinging a miss
ties a career high with 12 strikeouts
carson kelly a couple of strikeouts on
his ledger one two from burns
ground ball to third up with it
robertson gonna go the long way gets the
out
and it's six scoreless sittings for
corbin burns tyrone taylor flight out to
right with the bases loaded in the
fourth and the pitch swinging a drive
left and deep get up get out of here go
on
tyrone taylor
just hit a wicked line drive out of here
he hit a line drive that just cleared
the barrier and left but it got out of
here in a hurry it is two nothing
milwaukee strike away from a new career
high for corbin burns
got it
13 strikeouts for corbin burns some
emotion as he leaves the field after
seven scoreless toughest out of the day
for the brewers pitching staff ketel
marte coming up
away with a fastball in 97. williams
puts up the zero in the top of the
eighth inning one more to go it's david
peralta
ground ball first base shaw has it feeds
box burger
the sweep of the arizona diamondbacks is
complete this time a two-nothing shutout
and what a weekend here in milwaukee for
the brew crew